get into this elevator and LeBron James
gets in and Nate and I are immediately
like holy [__] it's LeBron yeah look at
each other like oh my God this [__]
LeBron like are we gonna say anything
and Nate gets his little smile like he's
gonna misbehave in some way and I'm like
okay I'm gonna let Nate say hi to LeBron
and Nate progazi goes hey LeBron
let me see your dick I start laughing so
hard Braun honestly he's about to get
mad and then he starts laughing
attention evaporates and he goes oh you
guys got jokes huh you comedians LeBron
goes you want to see this dick and goes
like he's gonna pretend to pull his
pants down and I'm like oh my I'm
laughing so [__] hard and it goes you
let me see your dick I will put one of
your pubes into my mouth and I will
swallow it and then I promise you I will
never brush my teeth again and LeBron
just looks at me he's like you want to
put one of my pubes in your mouth LeBron
reaches into his is like his sweatpants
Roots around Yanks and then hands Nate a
pubic neighbor gatsi puts it in his
mouth
and goes tastes like the goat